[Music]
column sony larry then june he used to
be the best of friends we're still the
best of friends no you're not who says
we're not sit somewhere else
now if i've done something to you just
tell me what i've done to you but you
didn't do anything to me
i just don't like you no more
you liked me yesterday
what does he not want to be friends with
anymore
why is he 12. what the hell's going on
with you me [ __ ] brother he's donald
siobhan
but he's always been done
the other night two hours you spent
talking to me about the things you found
in your little donkey shake that day
well it wasn't me little donkey [ __ ] it
was me pony's [ __ ] which shows how much
you were listening
if you don't stop talking to me
calm and if you don't stop bothering me
i have a set of shears at home and each
time you bother me from this day on i'll
take those shears and i'll take one of
my fingers off with them and i'll give
that finger to you until i have no
fingers left does this make things
clearer to you not really no starting
from now but just like you know
would you not want him to have to do the
one finger to see if he was bluffing
like no we wouldn't because worse comes
to worse so you can still play the
fiddle with four fingers i bet you going
back to your wrong guy no party are
talking to me are you
why aren't you talking to a parent my
mom
that wouldn't be a sin no would it
rather no but it's not very nice either
is it
do you know who we remember for how nice
they was in the 17th century oh
absolutely no one here we all remembered
the music at the time everyone to a man
knows mozart's name i don't there goes
that theory
[Music]
i can't be waiting around for any more
of this madness
let's just call it quits we won't call
it quits
we call it the start
you